The Needle Beetle is a clever device
that allows you to quickly select and
position needles for stitch patterning.
It is specific to the 6.5mm.
or 9mm machines
that don't have automatic patterning
(punch card or electronics).
Here are some facts the beetle will
repeat any 8stitch pattern repeat.
It only works from right to left.
Don't try to force it the other
way. To use it
you set up your stitch pattern over
the first 8 needles.
Use the beetle and the pattern repeat will
be duplicated across all
the needles in work.
The selected needles end up in "D" position.
Ready for stitch patterning
determined by your.
Carriage settings like slip and tuck.
Use the Knit it Now Cheat Sheets to make
it easire to set up complicated stitch.
Patterns, let's do a very simple example.
First, we have some needles in work
working over the first eight needles
on the right of the needles in work, align
the needles for every other needle set up.
Skip the first needle and put needles 2,
4, 6 and 8 into "C" position.
Now you don't have to be exact.
Notice the indicator on the needle bed
where the "C" position is.
Place the beetle on the needle bed.
If you have a lot of needles
in work, remove the knitting carriage so
you can place the beetle
on the needle bed.
With your hand and your fingers over
the beetle, pass it to the left.
You'll see that every other needle is
being selected and placed
in "D" position across the row.
This is duplicating, that first
8 sequence that you set up.
Here's another example.
This time, put all needles
into working position again.
Skip one needle on the right and pull just
two needles to "C" position
pass the beetle.
You'll see the selected stitch sequence
repeated across the row.
Using the Knit it Now
Cheat Sheets can help make
using the beetle even easier.
The grid is sized exactly for the
needle spacing on your machine.
Just copy the stitch pattern to the grid.
I like to use colored markers and hold
it up to the needle bed row by row.
To select the needles of your design.
You just need to select the first
8 needles and then let the beetle.
Repeat them across the row.
No more counting needles.
There's something to keep in mind.
You probably won't want
to pattern on the end needle.
So you'll want to copy the entire 8
stitches across the row and then return
the end needles to "B" position
so they don't tuck or slip.